hey what's up this is dr. John Delaney
with Ramsey Network what is happening
hope everybody's doing good and you're
catching up on these YouTube videos
we're having a blast here man I look
forward to talking to you all soon I'm
taking calls today actually my taking
calls I'm gonna answer some reader
emails here and by the way dude
everyone's clowning on me because of
this my computer is disgusting I'm gonna
get it cleaned up so don't be drinking
the hater-aide all right here we go here
is the first one hello dr. D I watched a
live telecast of marriage money mental
health on Wednesday and found it most
beneficial thank you and your talk you
mentioned communication is not
connecting can you please elaborate more
on this I've always heard that
communication is the key to any
successful relationship thus listening
to your comment confused me awesome use
of the word of thus haven't heard that
since the old King James Version Bible
that's pretty dope
I would appreciate further clarification
yes this is awesome question okay so
here's the deal
connection is not communication and so
what I what I mean by that is this
communication is just transferring
information and again we're talking
semantics here so if you can say we're
great communicators that means we sit
down and we talk to when we look each
other in the eye we hold each other's
hands where we hear each other we use
the same words we speak in pictures we
know what each other's saying if that's
communication to you awesome what
happens when we get stressed especially
during this pandemic time or especially
when people are feeling super lonely is
we start communicating by just using
words we start passing along information
here's a good example in my life I
texted my wife I love you all the time I
love you hope you have an awesome day I
love you take care and so what I'm doing
is I'm passing along information to her
right and she's getting in the cell
phone in black and white text that just
says I love you I love you I love you
so anywhere between 70 to 90 percent of
communication is spending depending on
what internet article you read or who
makes up what I've never seen actual
studies but so much of our communication
of our interaction is nonverbal right my
eyebrows they're huge
they move up and down like a always
moving my arms in my in my hands my face
my smile so much of the way we interact
is nonverbal and when I text somebody
just the characters I suck out 70 80
percent of our communication and just
make it text right that's just
information so if I've texted my wife I
love you
80 times today and I get a home I don't
feel like I need to say it anymore she
knows I have to communicate it I've
passed along information to her
that's not connecting and what happens
over time is even though we're passing
information back and forth hey what time
do I need to be here I need to leave in
this in the morning we homeschooled our
kids this morning and they're doing fine
or I I love you and I will see you at
five we're passing along information or
not connecting and so the way I would
differentiate communication from
connecting is making intentional time to
see each other to communicate full body
to look each other in the eye the whole
hand sometimes to hug just to feel one
another if you are quarantined away from
somebody that means getting on FaceTime
that means asking the words how are you
feeling how are you doing are you doing
okay really getting in depth to somebody
that's what I mean by connection and
what when you find yourself just
communicating you'll know it because you
start feeling distant you start feeling
separate you start passing along info
and you're not making these deep soul
connections every day if you're if
you've got somebody in your life you're
not quarantined away from them right so
let's say you're whoever your partner is
living at home hold their hands in the
morning and look them in the eye and say
how are you doing tell me how you're
doing
what's your picture of today look like
what's our picture of today look like
and how can I best serve you today and
then ask them to say that back do that
for one week and it's gonna feel super
awkward
super weird just tell them that some
YouTube Doc hack told you to do this for
a week that's gonna happy how you feel
the difference between communication
versus connecting and when you feel like
texting someone to say I love you call
them or you know do one of those Marco
Polo things where you can actually see
their face and you say
I love you it's not gonna be the same as
connecting but it's gonna be better than
just reading the text right do what you
can to put the screens down until the
people in the eye say I love you how you
doing how can I serve you this is dr.
John Bologna don't communicate Connect
connect and we will talk to you soon
make sure you subscribe and I'm just
pointing down because I'm assuming
there's a subscribe button somewhere or
it could be over here or over there and
I'll see you soon take care